pour que le sport maintenant entre dans
le 21e siècle il faut que l'impunité
cesse que les personnes qui sont
coupables soit traduit devant les
instances soit administratives soit
judiciaire mais voilà il faut donner un
signal fort assez victime assez sportif
qui pour certains d'entre eux je vous
l'assure était vraiment désespérés en
disant mais nous ça fait 20 ans qu'on
dénonce ça fait 20 ans qu'on dit les
choses et il ne sait rien passé
c'est des agressions sexuelles parfois
sur des victimes il y a très longtemps
qui sont maintenant adultes et qui
souhaitent témoigner et participer au
travaux de la commission c'est sur des
discriminations du racisme ça concerne
également des violences physiques ou
psychologiques ou même du harcèlement
dans le cadre aussi de personnes qui
travaillent dans ce mouvement sportif
mais il y a aussi des affaires sur la
question de corruption financière de
mauvais de mauvaises gouvernance dans
les clubs sportifs ou les fédérations ça
concerne beaucoup de fédérations
malheureusement en tout cas nous on a
reçu des témoignages sur on a reçu
finalement sur la Fédération des échecs
sur le volley-ball l'équitation le
football donc voilà c'est très très
diverse aussi ce qui nous a beaucoup
interpellé c'est le fait que les
sportifs n'avaient pas connaissance de
la cellule mise en place par le
Ministère des Sports donc ça fait deux
ans qu'elle existe elle est censée
recenser tous les faits de violence tout
ce qui ne va pas dans le milieu sportif
et les sportifs n'en n'ont pas
connaissance que ce soit l'INSEP ou même
que ce soit des personnalités comme
Laurent Blanc hier qui nous a avoué
qu'il n'était absolument pas au courant
l'existence de cette plateforme donc si
vous voulez à partir de ce moment là on
s'est dit mais comment aider ces
victimes qui visiblement ne trouvent pas
l'endroit où elles peuvent témoigner
quand elle témoigne parfois il y a pas
de suite et donc l'objectif pour nous
c'était aussi voilà de créer ce canal
pour qu'elle puisse justement trouver un
endroit où il y a plein d'informations
qui leur permettent de témoigner mais
aussi que on puisse tenir compte de
leurs témoignage dans le cadre de cette
commission d'enquête